Which is why the matrix was redesigned to this
peak of your civilization.
In 1989, the cold war ended in 2001. The twin towers fell,
but in between was an era of relative stability for America. The economy,
soared politicians, balanced the budget,
and the president played sax on our Cineo.
Even the Simpson saw the stability happening during the 1990s.
What's wrong with this guy, Andre and a man walked down the street,
but I been offered that job.
There's been plenty of discussion about movies,
reflecting the tragedy and chaos during the time they were made such as monster
movies, showing cold war anxieties and 21st century horror movies,
conveying fears of acts of terror.
But what about movies that came out during a time of general peace and security?
In other words, how can a film reflect stability?
Maybe one of the best years in film to explore this question is 1999.
Not only is it the turn of the millennia and the end of a prosperous decade,
but that you're also had many movies that deal with the stable uneventful world
of the nineties.
Let's see what the most popular movies can tell us about that unique moment in
history.
This is the world that, you know, world,
as it was at the end of the 20th century.
The nineties were defined by more than just a stability in the present because
of that stability people very actively looked into the future.
the.com bubble of the late nineties and early two thousands provides a great
example of this forward-thinking tech companies.
Weren't being valued on what they were currently worth,
but what they could be worth.
We marveled at our own magnificence as we gave birth to.
Of course, with those positive outlooks also came anxieties.
Technology led to fears of the Y2K bug.
The idea that the switch to the year 2000 would crash many vital computer
systems and create chaos.
It's actually what Peter has to fix at his job in office space.
From here we get what makes some 1999 movies.
So 1999 in general movies released in that year were not about surviving the
present because the present was actually going well.
They were about being tired of that stable presence and looking for a radically
different future.
It's a timely take on the hero's journey where the call to action isn't caused
by some ethics circumstance, but from the lack of ethic.
And yeah, what do you do there? I sit in a Cuban.
Cool, of course not all movies from that year, capture this idea,
especially the genre movies and movies from a different time period.
But the lack of Epic does exist in a surprisingly large amount of them.
Perhaps the most obvious symbol of that boring nineties lifestyle is from the
recurring image of the plane cubicle, which shows up in many movies from 1999,
there are classic visual reminder of the dead end job, a job that may be stable,
but has no future and no excitement.
It's from this powerful visual that I affectionately named the style of movie,
the cubicle movie,
but not every cubicle movie uses a literal cubicle to show this feeling.
The boondock saints is a crime thriller about the criminal underworld in Boston,
but even in a movie so far removed from corporate life,
it still clearly showcases Rocko having that same unfulfilling,
stable job as a package boy for the mob.
Remembered I've been working for those fat bastard since I've been an ice cream
place. You're me, man.
So you don't have to have a literal desk job to show this nineties anxiety.
Any character can be stuck this way so long as it feels corporate never changing
and stable to the point of boredom.
I'm a water saver.
It's not that filmmakers were actively trying to summarize the nineties climate
it's that every filmmaker made their movie within that period of time.
So that period will inevitably influence the production.
The cubicle movie has a premise based in that 90 stability.
So a significant percentage of these movies create conflict out of a very
similar atmosphere.
It doesn't really matter. I, uh,
I don't like my job and I don't think I'm going to go anymore.
The product of this stability is also monotony and monotony allows space for
introspection. As a result,
a lot of these films deal with identity and stories about private lives.
American beauty is about the inner lives of suburban neighbors.
While the setting of the film represents the idyllic American landscape of the
time, the characters represent the anxieties underlying that pristine exterior,
both the families have unfulfilling home lives.
The father is a borderline sexual predator and the neighbor is a secret white
supremacist who also happens to have repressed homosexual feelings.
This movie criticizes the perceived stability of the era,
suggesting that it's simply a mask that hides the true self,
the flowers in the garden,
the couch and the nineties lifestyle are not true beauty,
but rather mimicking beauty.
It's an artificial American beauty by club takes this opportunity for
introspection and turns it into a conversation about manhood a world without
conflict means a world where men don't have a way to assert their own
masculinity.
So the characters go to great lengths to manufacture conflict and chaos,
to satisfy their masculine impulses.
The movie satirizes this way of thinking as an ineffective and unproductive way
to find purpose, even though the film was intended as a cautionary tale,
many men took it a bit too. Literally, maybe the satire was too relevant.
Really.
The movie reminds us that the stability and uneventful illness of the nineties
was largely a middle-class white male phenomenon, film,
starring minorities or women like boys don't cry and all about my mother show us
that for some people, the nineties were anything but boring and stable.
These movies highlight the issues still present underneath that stable,
suburban exterior cubicle movie star,
men who have so little conflict in their life that they seek it out and they can
only really do so because they have the time and the money.
And there's no movie from 1999 that expresses the ideas of the cubicle movie
more than being John Malcovich.
The film exaggerates the oppressive corporate imagery in films like office space
by creating an absurd office with low ceilings here,
the office literally bears down on its employees when crack discovers a portal
that lets you live in John Malcovich his mind for 15 minutes,
he uses it to escape his boring life.
He even monetizes the portal and it has massive to people who are tired of their
boring lives and want to mimic the seemingly exciting life of a celebrity.
Craig uses Malcovich his status for sexual gratification and career goals,
but these shallow desires never lead him to true happiness.
Living the life of someone else means he never worked to make his own life
better.
He tried to escape his problems by mimicking someone else instead of exploring
what was within himself. Charlie Kaufman said,
he wrote the film while he worked as a writer on the TV show, get a life.
The best part of the show came from the scripts written by its original
creators. So all the other writers tried to imitate their voice.
The results he said was extremely unfulfilling.
Not only because it wasn't personal work,
but because mimicking someone else inherently means that you are not interesting
enough being John Malcovich. And to an extent,
all cubicle movies seem to reflect this idea in some way,
social forces compel us to conform ourselves into a certain definition of
success, like having the good job and a comfortable life,
but having to do this requires the belief that who we already are isn't good
enough. I think cubicle movies are trying to remind us that we are worth it.
The point is there doesn't have to be some crisis going on for a movie to
reflect world events.
1999 had this crazy phenomenon where nearly a dozen major Hollywood releases
feature a main character, tired of the stability,
monotony and uneventful illness of their life.
And it's a perfect mirror of what America was like in the late nineties.
The movies of that year reminded people to reclaim their confidence and search
for a more exciting and personal future. In other words,
they reminded us to party like it's 19. Now.
[Inaudible].
Truly understand the production of a movie.
You also have to understand the time period it was made.
In another classic example of history, influencing film is German.
Expression is cinema of the 1920s.
Not only should you watch some of those movies, but to understand them better.
I'd also recommend you learn about the impact of world war one on Germany,
which greatly altered their society. And in turn their movies,
you can learn more about that time in the secrets of world war,
one documentary available on CuriosityStream CuriosityStream has recently
expanded their library of documentaries to more than 2,400 titles,
about everything from history to technology.
These high quality videos are a great way to broaden your understanding of the
world around us. Go to curiosity, stream.com/.
Now you see it for unlimited access to the world's top documentaries and
nonfiction series. Enter the promo code.
Now you see it when prompted during the signup process and your membership is
completely free for the first 30 days.
Thanks for watching and thank you to my patriotic supporters who all got early
access to this video before the general public.
Yeah.